hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host grace helbig
so excited to have taylor tomlinson with
us today she's a stand-up comedian she's
an incredibly sweet human being she's
currently out on the road touring deal
with it her comedy hour that if you get
a chance to see her in any of your
cities that she's in you should we talk
about how she was raised in a very uh
religious and conservative household she
started out comedy in uh church to start
doing church shows and how wild of a
ride that is we also talk about the
mental health
aspect of it all and how candid she is
uh exploring and exposing her own mental
health issues on stage and uh online and
she gives some tips for finding a great
therapist and
uh we talk about what's next for her
just a little bit of everything in this
episode i had a lovely time talking to
taylor and i hope you enjoy it
not too deep but taylor tomlinson
[Music]
um thank you so much for making time to
talk to us you're in the middle of tour
right now right i am i am in the middle
of touring right now i'm touring forever
yeah how is that going and also i'm so
curious do you
is there a set route that you go on or a
set number of shows that you aim to do
or is it just kind of unrolling or
rolling out as you perform oh no i
basically just go wherever my agent
sends me
and tells me the routing makes sense so
we have you in these three places and
i'm like those seem kind of far away and
he's like no no it's fine
trust me from my desk you'll be fine
it seems okay yeah like this week i'm in
texas
and
you know you look at your schedule and
you're like oh austin dallas houston
that'll be fine and then you're like
well it's like a three-hour drive
between each of those places
and the alternative is like you take a
really short flight but then you got to
go to the airport and you're at the
mercy of airlines and whatnot was just
easier to drive but driving through
texas is not very entertaining
[Music]
so much time to think
about everything
okay well i want to go back and hear
your story about how you got into comedy
to begin with i
uh you started as like a teenager doing
stand-up mm-hmm yeah i have a very
uncool story perfect i
uh my dad wanted to take a stand-up
comedy class from like a church comedian
i grew up very religious uh when i was a
junior in high school and so that's how
i started doing stand-up is in a class
with my dad who i think thought
you know
we would just hang out or something like
i think he thought he was funny and i
was like
a writer like he's like yeah we finally
he absolutely was not taking me thinking
like you could do this at all wow um and
so yeah i started in like churches and
like schools and like corporatey things
weirdly enough like because i just
wasn't allowed in comedy club until i
was 18.
so
uh you know it was it was a very strange
beginning and it wasn't until i was like
you know 18 19 that i started going up
in comedy clubs and i was like oh this
is where comedy's supposed to happen
these people react differently yeah
what is it
what's like the vibe of a church
comedian like i can guess or assume
uh but based on your experience like
what's that person like
that person is typically a a a very
conservative middle-aged family man
that's typically what it is so i don't
know why churches were hiring me at 16
17. wow to come in and just make fun of
the fact that i hadn't been asked to
prom that year like
it was so dumb
they were using you to reach the younger
audience for them
i did look i played a few singles events
for sure oh hell yeah which are which
are some weird crowds in a in a church
on a tuesday night
with a heart hanging off across
so strange so much imagery
but the okay so do you now
attract any religious audiences
or has that ship sailed
i think i get a lot of people who grew
up religious i don't know how many
people i get who are still like devout
christians
but i get a lot of people who are like
oh my gosh i grew up that way too and
like relate to the jokes i make now
about growing up that way because it is
such a part of you and so so in your
bones kinda uh and so much to untangle
as you get older
yeah and it's just like so much low
hanging fruit of
constant paradox and like uh
just
total things that do not make sense or
contradict each other very often it
seems yes yes
so when you move from doing
safer church related things into like
more traditional stand-up comedy was it
like a culture shock for you and did you
have to say like this is still something
i really want to do
yeah i think it was i mean i i hadn't
been to a comedy club
until i turned 18 and then i just went
to watch a show yeah
and i think part of me hoped i wouldn't
like it because then i could stay
you know in in my parents good graces
you know what i mean i'm like well if i
can just be if i just could be a church
comedian but i didn't really see that
for myself and i didn't want to and i
didn't know what i believed and yeah i i
do think part of me was like well at
least i i know what i'm doing over here
and i have such bad anxiety i was like
man i don't want to
figure out how to navigate this this
club world
and i just loved it so much i was like
damn it okay
but i was really really clean material
wise until i was like 22. so i was i was
church friendly for a really long time
before i was like i i would like to talk
about some other things because if
you're playing churches even a little
bit even if you're only doing a church
every once in a while
they will fire you for a tweet that has
innuendo in it wow
wow they did that
yo yeah you're like this sucks i don't
want to like
build my career in this space where you
can be canceled for just being human
yeah and it is kind of funny that they
have so much time in between all their
loving of the lord to look through your
social media i know right i'm like
shouldn't you have been praying i don't
know
seems strange well you talk about
anxiety and one of the big things that i
love that you talk about so candidly is
mental health stuff this therapy is all
that jazz um i'm curious if that
was just something that was so true to
you that you couldn't not talk about it
or if it was kind of like a conscious
effort to be able to bring that to stage
oh no unfortunately um i just have a lot
of [ __ ] i'm working on
personally
and i'm i'm not good at writing jokes
that are about anything other than my
own life and my own experiences uh i
wish i was i wish i was purely
observational i was like have you guys
been to panera bread i wish i was that
but i'm not and so
you know
it it's just what i'm
personally
going through
yeah is what ends up on stage so
um i think that's what it is i also like
you know you get
you get kind of like low-key disgusted
with yourself
if you're posting too much
like cool [ __ ] online yeah a hundred
percent i think you do a really great
job of towing the line between you know
cool [ __ ] and your promotional stuff and
then also just like real raw this is
what i'm going through right now with
not necessarily a punch line to it which
is very i think
nice i
think sometimes people think comedians
might be disingenuous with like their
pain or their struggle or wherever it
might be looking for the punchline for
it
um
i'm curious with that as you talk about
therapy
do you have tips for finding a good
therapist
oh gosh i mean
i think you have to treat it like dating
yeah i think a lot of people
will see one therapist and therapists
are people too and some of them are
terrible yeah that isn't that crazy to
realize that really kind of um
disillusioned me for a while because i
was of the mindset that like i i have a
lot of anxiety
and i just a therapist as a therapist
and me getting to therapy is a huge
success and then realizing that hmm this
isn't helping that much is it me or is
it them oh it's them oh no
yeah it's really hard and like
a lot of times the really good ones
aren't covered by insurance because
they're really good and they don't have
to take insurance totally so it's just
it's very expensive and you
know thank god there's things like
better help and stuff but
i mean even that like i've tried every i
tried two different like app based
therapy
things and like didn't like either of
those people but i have friends who have
done it and they found like the perfect
person on the first try
i saw somebody years ago for like a year
and she was good for like a year and
then she stopped being good
or i did i'm not really sure like
sometimes you have relationships and
they only last a year and that's very
true
you get what you need and then the
therapist i have now was recommended to
me by my psychiatrist that's good so you
just have to find one yeah that where
one mental health professional that
works for you and then go who do you
like
yes these are serious yeah so true
uh and also i have to remind myself that
like
i guess the ultimate goal of therapy is
to not
be in it forever
and that if they're doing a good job
i might not need to see this person
continuously in the future
that's possible i i
i don't dare to dream that big for
myself i'm hoping to get down to like
twice a month that would be cool yeah
yeah yeah baby steps
hell yeah
uh and talking about like the stuff you
reveal on stage
you said that you obviously prefer to
write stuff that you've experienced do
you draw a line on like how personal
you'll get or how personal the things
you'll talk about will be
you know it's so hard because there have
been times that
i wrote jokes about things
that i then decided like you know what
i'm just not gonna do this
and then later on i find a better way to
talk about it or
it's
i'm trying not to work through things on
stage yeah so much that was a question
too like do you approach
bringing up something that is like
thought through but not necessarily
resolved innerly for yourself versus
like i've got a handle on this so now i
can retroactively talk about the chaos
of going through x y or z i think now
i'm trying to do the latter but
previously i was doing the former i
remember my old therapist said that at
one point where she was like maybe we
just keep some of this in here for us
and i was like you think we're talking
about anything i haven't written a joke
about like i'm here because the writing
a joke about it didn't work like you're
the last stop
on the healing journey for me
um but you do
i i think that writing jokes about stuff
will help
but only up to a point because
you are still talking about it every
night yeah and like the hour i'm doing
right now we're getting ready to film
the next special in a few weeks and i'm
really looking forward to not doing this
hour anymore because i am proud of it
and i like it but it's just like a it's
very personal and it's a lot to talk
about
and
every night i'm like why am i so drained
like this is like
this just feels very tiring yeah and i
think it's because i am sharing so much
yeah i mean especially when it's
really true to you and stuff that is
meaningful because it's like heavy [ __ ]
occasionally like that will exhaust you
because you're human it proves you're
human and not a robot that's very cool
yeah i mean hopefully i'm sure some
people are like i mean make an
appointment
with your therapist what are you doing
here we're trying to have date night
um but i am again i am proud of it and
i'm i'm happy with where everything's
ended up but a lot of the things i'm
talking about in
the hour on tour right now is like stuff
that i
worked through for years and i'm still
consciously working through
it were things that i thought i worked
through and then realized i hadn't
based on how it was affecting other
areas of my life because if you don't
deal with that like deeper [ __ ]
it starts popping up in like your
personal relationships and like your
approach to your career
and you go like oh my god does this all
really go back to this one thing that
happened to me when i was a kid
[ __ ]
[ __ ] i know i get the formula of the
child trauma
constantly pushes through into the
unconscious unconscious and all that
jazz um but i i get sick of that being
the formula and i'd like to just be at
the conclusion now for myself
oh my god yeah the um so workshopping so
you're about to film your special uh a
new one the what's the process like to
go out and to workshop a full hour do
you try to get it into its totality
before you even bring it to stage or are
you kind of putting it together in
pieces while you are out on the road oh
you're definitely putting it together in
pieces while you're out on the road i
mean once we get this filmed i'll
probably i already have you know
whatever 15-20 minutes that isn't going
in this hour
that will then become like the base for
the next one
and i already have like a vague idea of
sort of
the
subjects i want to touch on
in the next one and how that's all gonna
come together but wow it's yeah it's
really like
because once you film a special it's
like a countdown until it comes out and
then once it comes out everybody's like
well we don't want to watch that if we
come buy tickets to see you live
and i am filming this special in the
middle of a tour
which
is maybe not the way you're supposed to
do it but it's what i'm doing
um
so you know it it'll probably come out
towards the end of this tour
and then by that point i'll hopefully
have a brand new hour or at least an
hour that wasn't um
the special
but yeah it takes a long time it takes
like a couple years to
write all the material
do it all together figure out what makes
sense to do together
the last like month or so
i was adding jokes that were newer and
then realized i had too much
stuff and so then i was like taking
jokes away
and now i'm still at a point where i'm
like okay
we want it to be this length it's this
length now but that leaves some leeway
so we can cut stuff out later so we're
just gonna film all of it and then
probably edit
and uh it's really it's just a lot of
spinning plates yeah i mean yeah it
seems like it's a constantly evolving
process for yourself it must be no
wonder you're tired
thanks for making time to talk to us but
then we go take a nap after this so
tired
um okay we're gonna take a quick break
when we get back i have more questions
for you so we'll be right back but more
not too deep
[Music]
hello listeners grace helbig here
wanting to say two things a big thank
you for listening to the podcast uh if
you're a regular listener if this is
your first time listening welcome and
thank you and uh second thing if you are
enjoying yourself here in this not too
deep world we've built and you'd like to
leave us a review that would be so
wonderful if you can go to the itunes
store the app store and leave us a
lovely little review comment how are you
feeling good bad otherwise maybe just
good or otherwise would be appreciated
other than that enjoy the podcast
do you have like rituals before you
perform or when you're traveling since
it is
so much just like out of your control
yeah if i'm
exhausted i try to nap
uh which happens like half the time
and i'm not a huge
i have not been a coffee person in the
past and now that i tour like this like
kind of have to be on the road yeah and
actually lately i was getting back home
on you know sunday monday
and feeling like just [ __ ] for like a
day and i'm like why do i feel so bad i
thought i was sick the first time and
i'm like oh my god the first week out
i'm already sick and i came to realize
it was
just caffeine withdrawal because
i was drinking like
five coffees a day just to get through
it because i would
get up early
fly all morning or all day yeah and then
you know have two hours to get ready and
then go do two shows and two meet and
greets
and go back to the hotel to go to sleep
and do it again in the morning and i was
having like a coffee in between shows
just to keep it going yeah
so
it's you know it's been interesting
i'm sure i mean yeah i'm also caffeine
like is big crutch situation so i don't
know how you would do it otherwise like
i don't see how people i guess you will
meditate
right here i can't i can't keep up with
it but also caffeine's like so bad for
your anxiety so yeah it's such a
nightmare like any time that i have
gotten off of caffeine it's always
lasted like a month and i'm like i feel
really good like once the headaches
subside and you stop wanting to kill
yourself yeah you're like wow good for
me and then you're like i could have it
every once in a while and then pretty
soon you're just back in it
because it's it's necessary
yeah
it's a double-edged sword that all
caffeine
do you if you talk to someone when
you're traveling that's a stranger and
they ask you what you do do you say that
you do comedy or do you try to avoid
that
oh i try to avoid it usually it's like a
rental car counter situation they'll be
like what are you in town for and i'm
like oh just work
and if they're like
what do you do then sometimes i'll be
like
oh comedian or other times i'll just be
like ah it's boring just nothing i've
said real estate before yeah i don't
know
i don't know if that even counts but i'm
just like oh it's really not interesting
like i just i try to avoid it but then
also my email has the
has like comedy in it so i'm like i
should change this so people don't know
and my credit card will say it my
business credit card will say it so
you're like oh this was i didn't think
this through but yeah if i'm in like an
uber or something i'll absolutely lie i
am i'm not trying to have the
what have you done conversation and tell
me a joke
um
okay we're gonna switch gears a little
bit and i'm gonna now ask you the two
questions i ask every single guest
that's on the podcast uh the first is
who alive or dead would you most like to
throw cold spaghetti at
oh
i guess i guess somebody who's into that
somebody i'm sure
the first person who comes up when you
google
cold spaghetti fetish
because i don't want to cause anyone any
harm
that's really considerate i also don't
know
i truly have no guess
at all into who the first person would
come up and i don't know if i want to
venture down that search path i'm gonna
guess they're on reddit yeah
oh yeah for sure but yeah that's i'll go
with that that's very considerate of you
um the other question i ask every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
shooting story or like a bathroom
emergency situation but
you can only use three words or like
small phrases to describe the event so
for example mine is college jogging
front lawn
oh okay
ooh three words is hard or like a little
phrase
afraid like can i use like four words
yeah oh yeah okay
um
i will say i appreciate this extremely
moody lighting on whatever
the sun came out in new york no i love
it it only adds to the ambiance of what
this narrative will be
um okay i mean this might be four or
five words i'm gonna say a
high school marching band parade
oh
wow were you in marching band in high
school yes okay i was that's even better
for the story
oh oh yeah no i didn't like interrupt a
parade
either way
it's a lovely and horrifying
um okay now we have a section of the
podcast called deep and hot where we
have a deep question prepared for you
and uh we're gonna ask you a hot take on
something um that comes to mind so
deep question for you is do you allow
yourself to feel successful
ooh that's a good one
i try to i'm trying to get better at it
because i found that being
self-deprecating and humble is sometimes
really annoying
for yourself
no for other people yeah there's there's
um what did i i read some uh probably a
buzzfeed article about how gen z the
things that they hate about millennials
the it's like cringe culture and like
self-deprecating humor that they're like
over it no i was like [ __ ] you guys
i think
they're over self-deprecating humor they
think it's unnecessary now i think
they're a culture of like mental health
self-love situation but buzzfeed didn't
expand on it so who knows what the
actual reality is of that but i think a
millennial wrote that
i do i'm with you though that like
i
find
people that
uh kind of effortlessly exude humility
very attractive in like a soul sense
um but i do find that people get sick of
that as well and i don't know what the
alternative is i am a very not confident
person and like bragging about myself in
any way
yeah i think people
want you to be grateful
and humble
but not self-deprecating and dismissive
and downplaying i think it's like
a very
a very
hard
line to tow at times because i tend to
be very like well you know i only got
this because of this or that like
anything to take and people get really
annoyed they're like shut up like
just shut up okay or if you're like
complaining about
you're afraid of this or that and people
like you should just appreciate how well
things are going
like people just want you to be grateful
and i i think it's fun to watch people
be excited
about
being successful like i feel that way
looking at people i consider to be
successful is when they're like oh my
gosh i'm i feel so lucky i can't believe
i get to do this
and i'm i'm so grateful and stoked for
what's happening yeah
i think that's
a good place to be um so that's where i
try to i try to live is just like man
this is really cool and i'm glad that i
got here and i can't believe it and
you know there are always going to be
people
more successful than you people less
successful than you that deserve it just
as much as you like it's good to have
perspective
but it's also important to to let
yourself
feel good about what you've accomplished
i think yeah i'm with you it's so much
easier said than done it's okay
truly a practice and gratitude i guess
but then also yeah i'm with you that
like
i don't know why i can see other people
feeling good about their success and
feel good for them too but have such a
difficult time doing it myself
yeah and nobody wants to listen to
somebody complain about
how they
are unhappy or want more
when they are doing well yeah
because that's not
attractive either like
so the answer is
yes
sometimes i do but i have to i have to
work on it it's like being present you
know you have to go like hey take a step
back
look at where you are and what you're
doing and
be aware of the fact that this is what
you wanted and now it's happening
and be present for it because
you spent all this time thinking about
it and now
you're gonna miss it if you
spend the time that it's happening going
yeah but i don't i don't deserve it and
i shouldn't i shouldn't be here and i'm
not really that successful because i
don't have what this person has like
it's just
yeah
hey i'm with you um
all very
relatable uh thoughts
with that
i guess this kind of uh
associates with that
hot take on
if you think social media is
a real
window
into
a person
i think so yeah yeah oh yeah i
absolutely do because even if people are
posting like
polished versions of themselves
how people want to present themselves to
the world is a window into who they are
i think yeah
so i think if someone's all selfies
you're like well i kind of know who that
person is
i may not know what they look like in
the morning but i i think i get a sense
of who they are at least a little bit
yeah do you what's your relationship
with social media generally speaking
i mean it's just part of my job it's
it's one of those things where you're
like if i
wasn't working in entertainment would i
even have this
because i have a friend who got off of
it
while she was in law school and she's
like oh my god i feel
so free she's like i never think about
posting
she's like i have this blank profile now
i have to like check on you and the few
friends i want to
keep up with like she was on instagram
the way my grandma's on instagram yeah
she's just like i have this blank
profile
with a suggested username to to watch
people's stories who i love
but yeah i really i fantasize about that
where i'm like that would be amazing but
it's it's a chore it's really a chore
yeah it's um
it's very tough and evolving is there a
platform that you prefer
or is there a platform that you
absolutely hate and try to stay off as
much as possible
uh i don't know if anybody is anyone on
facebook anymore i think i think i
technically am but i don't run it yeah
um
instagram we've all worked so hard on
and now that's starting to feel uncool
because i feel like i blinked last when
the pandemic started and was like i'm
gonna try and figure this instagram
thing out and now everyone's like we're
over on tick tock uh and no one looks at
that [ __ ] right now
i know it's so hard it's so hard but
tick tock is really fun i really like
tic toc i mean i posted a tick tock uh
months ago because i thought i was
having uh
reoccurring utis and it turns out i got
all these comments on it of people who
are like have you tried this have you
tried this one like obviously
but there were a few people who were
like oh it might be this other thing
that's
not that because i was going to the
doctor and they're like you don't have a
uti
and so then i had to like see this is
again this is me over sharing no it's
great this is helping
i finally i saw like a sp
someone multiple people on tick tock
were like you have to see like a like a
gyno urologist and i was like what even
is that
and i found one and i went to her and
she was like she's like oh you have
pelvic floor dysfunction and i was like
what
that's but i had heard of it because of
that tick tock post because a bunch of
people had said i thought i had this but
i didn't have i wasn't getting
infections at all and that's why every
time i went to the doctor they were like
you're completely fine
um but you were in a lot of pain and
it's like
you just have to like stretch and like
not be stressed it sucks the doctor was
like you can do a phys she's like if it
doesn't get better we'll do physical
therapy she's like but it's like it's
like anxiety essentially wow
it sucks so hard wow and so tick-tock
helped you
get to that conclusion
wow so it is a helpful place okay i
think it is also it just feels like
not as many people who know you are on
it even though that's not true
yeah
it's uh yeah it's me it's it's i haven't
committed myself to like using it
consistently because it just i feel like
a grandmom on there being like this is
too overwhelming but every person is the
funniest person on here and i have
nothing to contribute to this platform
whatsoever i can just observe from a
distance like a creep but who am i to
try and do what these people have
already figured out completely
360. oh i'm just watching
like 22 year old girls
turn their vans into a home
and drive across the country
going like should i be doing that and
it's like no you're old do you have a
fantasy backup plan if let's say in some
hypothetical bizarro universe comedy
ceases to exist tomorrow is there some
like a
re renovating a van and driving
cross-country situation that you would
endeavor into
i mean
when i was younger i just wanted to
write like young adult novels yeah and
like live in the woods yeah
but i'm too scared to live in like an
isolated place by myself so i'd want to
live in like a rural area but there's
still like
a good amount of houses around yeah
you know like
like suburbs
well not quite like like less than the
suburbs i know but i feel like that's
exactly the place that i'm because i'm
reaching my max capacity on how much i
can handle in los angeles like how just
icky it makes me feel
on my insides and i'm like actively
trying to figure out what is that sweet
spot
town city
not completely remote but also not new
york city kind of city
that offers all of those things i do
think about that like when nighttime
hits in those like beautiful
picturesque places it's just pitch
[ __ ] dark out and then animals come
out and who knows what else yeah and uh
that's where my brain wanders to that's
real night time right there yeah exactly
that's nighttime with a capital n
do you
watch anything in between working are
you watching anything that you're
obsessed with now or when you're
succession's back so
it is very interesting
uh other than succession i don't know
shows wise is that what we're talking
about yeah anything that's like your
go-to if you have time you're like i'm
just gonna binge something right now or
i'm gonna like i'm obsessed with reality
tv so that's all for me
when i have time yeah i wish i was a
reality tv person because there's so
much of it
i don't i just don't love reality tv
i've never been able to get into it
because i'm like this isn't real
i know you stay pure
it's
a
sticky web
i mean but neither is like 30 rock which
i keep watching over and over like i
just i think i don't appreciate being
lied to
i think i have real trust issues and
someone they're like i found the love of
my life i'm like you did not like i'm
fine with like
but i'm fine with watching this but
let's not pretend yeah you know what i
mean but then every once in a while you
know
it is real i guess i don't know i can't
get into it um so i end up just like
binging you know 30 rock or parks and
rec for like the 50th time nice
comfort watches on the road are
important totally and i mean they're
just classics just jokes jokes jokes my
appreciation from before reality tv has
just evolved into
everyone that's
on these programs now seems to
understand like the tropes of it and
understand like the framework of making
a reality tv show so it there to me is
always this undercurrent of castmates or
cast members trying to write their own
narrative
just suppose against what the producers
are going to edit their narrative into
and so i love watching when someone is
trying to push their own storyline and
it doesn't go
how you can imagine they want it to go
that's incredible and that makes me want
to watch reality tv it's all i mean that
to me is what the real housewives have
boiled down to now it's just women
coming on with exactly who they think
they are and what they're going to show
television and then it all just explodes
in the face i
love that
angle so much
if you ever have uh if you get like a
stomach flu or something and you have so
much time i highly recommend watching
with that lens and it's pretty fun
this season of the real housewives
sponsored by the flu yeah exactly well
you're from orange county right
yeah i'm from riverside county
is that adjacent to it yeah it's close
to orange county so i feel like you grew
up in real life with the people that are
on like
uh real housewives of orange county and
all of that so it probably is a bit
triggering to watch that show yeah i'm
like i get it i get what we're doing
over here
um okay we're gonna take one last break
when we get back uh we have a question
that has been submitted by a listener
that maybe you can offer some advice on
so we'll be right back not too deep
[Music]
okay taylor we're back in
and we have a
question that has come from a listener
viewer and it's about
friendship so um they say i need some
advice i have a group of three friends
that i consider my closest friends at
the moment but for some reason i'm the
one in the group they always pick on
they'll joke about how dumb or ditzy or
not good at certain things and
i am and usually i laugh it off but
lately it's been getting to me more they
definitely do it to me more than anyone
else in the friend group
uh i want to say something but i don't
want to come off as too sensitive or
dramatic especially since they always
say they're just joking when they say
these things i also feel anxious to
confront them as a group what do you
think i should do or say
oh that's tough yeah um
my first question would be
ask yourself are you really laughing it
off
[Music]
because if you're laughing
they might think you really do think
it's funny yeah like if you're like too
convincing i don't know how good an
actor you are um
but also are you like
reacting to it in like a fun way you
know how some people
some people i'm i'm this type of person
i think where
i can be fun to make fun of
because i will
react a lot to it yeah i'd be like oh my
god seriously like i'll do like that
[ __ ] yeah and if it's coming from like a
loving friend you're like you really do
mean it you think it's funny and you
don't feel hurt by it
but
i think like
that can that can happen sometimes where
you fall into that role in the friend
group
because
your friends genuinely think
that
you're like sparring like everybody it's
just a bit you guys are all doing yeah
they make fun of you and you kind of
react and it's just like a ping pong but
if you just kind of like
don't react to it
it feels awkward and i think people
don't want to do it anymore if you just
kind of like
stonewall it yeah
like i've done that with people who try
to make fun of me or be too familiar and
i don't feel close to them where you'll
just kind of be like
oh yeah like you just you just react to
them very
in a very boring way or like well you
know because you're so dumb you're like
or like oh you you just seem really
upset and you're like not really i'm
actually doing fine like yeah yeah yeah
that you don't because it
if you are trying to be polite and like
laughing it off like you say and not
trying to be sensitive because i hate
that people attribute sensitivity to
like less than or weakness or whatever
it is or it being annoying uh because
i've learned that i'm a highly sensitive
person and it's like oh right it does
feel like it sucks but it's also just
part of you
uh
and so yeah if you're laughing you're
probably giving them an impression that
you're enjoying
this ribbing or whatever it is in your
group also
if there is a place where this is like
getting too much and
i would
if you have a group of three
friends
figure out who you think might be the
easiest to talk to about it like i don't
know if addressing all three of them at
once is the right way to do it because
it's still they've strengthened their
numbers
uh but if there's one per particular
person that you feel closest to or like
safest just being like i don't want to
be dramatic but like i am starting to
get hurt feelings and i don't want to
build resentment in our friendship like
that's not fun for me
uh and then maybe they're able to relay
that to the other two in some capacity
yeah that's a that's a good that's good
advice i would also say like
i would preface it with them of going
like i know you guys are kidding yeah i
know you're my friends like because
they'll get defensive and be like what
we're kidding like shut up like yeah to
kind of head that off any response like
you are being dramatic or too sensitive
i would just say like look i know you
guys don't mean anything by it
i ages doesn't make me feel good to hear
it over and over
even if i know that
like
have you ever had to have you ever had
anyone come up to you about any of the
comedy you've done on stage
that
it was a personal friend or loved one
that was like hey
i don't
want you to say that about me or
whatever it is
i ran a joke
past my
grandma at one point that i was doing
like years ago yeah and i ran it past
her to make sure she was okay with it
and at first
she was and then like the next day she
texted me and she was like you know what
i've just been thinking about it and i
was like done it's gone like yeah
completely gone
don't worry about it because like to me
there's no joke that's
worth your relationships yeah
and that i mean that bodes well because
if these friends really really love you
and they hear you say like um this hurts
my feelings
hopefully they'll have hearts enough to
be like you got a dude
noted it might not be we might
accidentally do it here and there
because it's natural for us but
know that it's not falling on deaf ears
your concerns
yeah um
taylor we've gotten towards the end of
the podcast
what is coming up next for you outside
of shows is there anything else and the
new special eventually is there a
timeline on all of that
there is not a timeline on all of that i
have no idea um when that i'm just kind
of focusing on getting it done first
um
but yeah i mean i'm
i'm starting
uh a solo podcast that'll be out in like
a couple weeks i don't know when this
comes down um but
but who knows how long that'll last
that's bold a solo podcast wow good for
you
look i just don't have
the
i don't have a schedule that allows me
to have other people on it with me oh
yeah so it's pretty much just gonna be
me and my producer um
talking about all the places i'm
traveling and also the fact that i am by
coastal and living in two different
places and trying to like the east coast
when i'm from the west coast and and all
that good stuff because i think a lot of
people in their 20s and 30s are like
trying to figure out where they want to
live totally kind of like what we were
talking about
um
especially after the pandemic a lot of
people like moved home or
decided they didn't want to live where
they were living for whatever rent they
were paying
so it's kind of about that i don't know
how long it's going to go for but i'd
like to uh speaking of working through
stuff you're going through on your own
in a public medium
that's kind of what we're doing so great
ready for that follow me on taylor
tomlinson and instagram taylor thompson
comedy on tick tock t-town comedy.com
for tickets i'm on tour forever amazing
um before you leave we like to give our
guests a little token of our
appreciation um and it's a personalized
horoscope from us to you that melissa
just put in the chat if you'd like to
read it aloud
okay
dear scorpio scorpion of the stars
when the sun and mercury conjoin in
sagittarius it will be prime time to
boost your self-esteem and confidence
maybe try some mirror mantras like meet
man with dreams crush his dreams
just over and over maybe
it's in the stars
i will i will start i'll start doing
that mantra i'm so glad that my
self-esteem is about to be boosted hey
for all of us we're in eclipse season or
something i don't know exactly what that
means but i see a lot of astrologists
talking about it over on instagram
then it must be true exactly everything
on the internet is true
taylor thank you so much this has been
so lovely to chat with you um
make sure you guys are going following
her in real life at shows and on the
internet uh and good luck with the
special
thank you so much thank you for having
me of course we'll see you guys next
time on another episode of not too deep
goodbye
too deep too deep too deep deep not too
deep with christ
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry and an
extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music